it's amazing that that interception by
Richard Sherman came six years to the
day the six year anniversary of him
tipping a Kapernick pass into the hands
of his eventual Super Bowl MVP teammate
Malcolm Smith to send the Seahawks to
the Super Bowl over the 49ers and then
six years later an interception of his
own seals the deal for the 49ers life is
amazing is it not Richard Sherman you
know I mean honestly it is crazy how
these things happen what was that like
seeing that ball in the air last night
Richard well it was it was it was cool I
wasn't sure I was gonna be able to get
the house it was a freaking you know
Aaron just flicks it and it goes 80
attracted nuts you know
use every bit of little gas I had a
cleansing tank to go get it but once I
knew I could get there you know it'd be
cool it's a special moment so like what
have you been able to I guess just sit
there just sit there for a moment in the
last 1215 hours about your journey and
the fact that you're going with a team
that you spent so much of your first
several years preventing from happening
and it's the six year anniversary of it
happening I'm just wondering if you've
been able to sit there and react to what
this means to go back to the Super Bowl
with a different team it's really cool
it's really special you know I really
loved this team and you know there's a
lot of love and appreciation in this
locker room and that's what you that's
what you what you enjoy most you know
you can't control the wins and losses
you know they come and go but it's the
Brotherhood at the family the friends
you make throughout the journey to make
it special is there a moment where you
realize that all came together this year
it was early early in all season
training camp any specific moment where
you're like okay this this kind of adds
that feeling to it honestly I can't
think of any specific moment because it
was all throughout the year you know
throughout the year you you have
different experiences with different
people you know obviously you have a ton
of interactions with your position group
and ton of you know back and forth and
relationships and and you go deeper
because you see them that those
so much about the year you have you have
dealings with the o-line d-line the
linebackers the running bags the
quarterbacks and you really get a chance
you know whether it's on the plane or in
the locker room after game or our home
one of those long road trips that we
stayed on the East Coast or stayed in
Youngstown Ohio and you get to have
conversations you really get to know
your teammate Richard Sherman here on
the Rich Eisen show I just remember you
know you came on earlier in the season
and two-and-oh and then obviously four
no five I know and you came on and I'm
like you know how does this make it is
this anything close to the Seattle teams
and you kind of let me know in a passive
way passive-aggressive way to pump the
brakes a little bit and and and it is
just amazing how it took awhile for
everyone a warm up to the idea that the
49ers were for real now you're in the
Superbowl is there any sort of football
spike that you you you kind of want to
make right now even obviously before
winning at all not really you know I
just want to enjoy this moment with my
teammates and enjoy the ride you know I
think it's you know as you get older and
you haven't been for a while like I
haven't been in what five six years you
appreciate it different you know some
guys you know obviously in this locker
room I think outside of Jimmy and there
might be one other person that's ever
been just in the playoffs in general
it's gonna be a really special moment um
and it's gonna be really cool for them
to just make the Super Bowl and and see
what the experience is like but they
also understand that the moment Richard
Sherman 49ers cornerback here on the
Rich Eisen show okay I'd love for you to
dive deep into raheem most hurt and his
story here that many people are just
finally beginning to learn because of
his remarkable performance on Sunday
what has it been like to watch him work
and make if you will the most of this
situation
the whole season and just throughout
this whole journey man it's since I've
been here he's been a incredible special
teams player and just an incredible
player in general and just really really
taking it in his own hands and and and
taking the destiny in his own hands and
just freakin works as hard as anybody
out
see and you see in fruits of his labor
and it's cooled up or opacity you know
how grateful play last night
yeah and I'm wondering if there's any
sort of connection here Richard between
this team and again the Seahawks teams
that you you were on in the fact that
this is a Super Bowl team without a
single if you will skilled position
player on offense that was a first-round
draft choice and just a remembering
outside of obviously Earl Thomas the
Legion of boom that you were forming
along with Bobby Wagner upfront in that
that NASCAR a defensive line their
roaring a lot of first-round draft
choices yourself included does that at
all remind you of the past here well I
mean it's just totally different you
know different teams different
experiences and you know I don't wanna I
don't wanna
with downplay either side you know I'll
be a you know look at and see how it was
really special but this is totally a
different game and an incredibly unique
and they deserve their own unique
perspective and that's why I retreated
you know I don't sort of compare and
contrast and and go back and forth that
way you know this is a special team as
the San Francisco 49ers was totally
different group of men
and and I'm grateful to be a part of it
you know we were the number one defense
they were number two in total defense
and and we're still growing we're still
playing we're still fighting we're still
working to perfection so in a few
minutes I have left with you here
Richard Sherman on the Rich Eisen show
what what first blush issues do the
Chiefs present to you they're obviously
a tremendous offense and and you can see
what their dynamic receivers do Pat
mahomes obviously Travis Kelce they have
a ton of weapons defensively you know
Frank cards is disruptive Tyrann Mathieu
is a huge huge huge disrupter in their
defense in the middle Chris Jones
presents to their own issues so it's
gonna be tremendous for us and what's up
with the Revis Richard are you in here
not on the Christmas card list because I
have to get rid of you with him and
talking time to talk to him about it
[Music]
I really got nothing for him but he
seems to have some you know got too much
time on his hands or something yeah I
mean he's taking pictures of you and you
know on the screen and talking about how
you don't travel or have helping a
defensive scheme that he never had I'm
just wondering why did did you and he
ever tangle in any way shape or form
that were unaware of with one of those
where work guy who who thinks more of
themselves in the world thinks of them
and and doesn't feel like I'm getting
more credit than I deserve or something
like that and you know obviously his
stats don't match my stats and so he
tries finding other ways to make himself
relevant in the conversation I did
notice that you were on the on the side
of Davante Adams to start the game
you did move around I mean it's not like
you right I didn't notice that correct
well like I said before I just do what
the game plan is you know I played the
game plan I mean doing my coach shows me
to do regardless I'll give it to him you
know he he acts like he called the plays
and defenses he played in he didn't you
know just like his year in Tampa
whenever playing zone he's getting
cooked up you know but it was like oh my
god he that's not the system for me it's
like when your great corner whatever
system you're playing is system for you
now you're the first player age 31 or
older with multiple interceptions in a
playoff run since Edie Reed do you think
of the Hall of Fame for yourself Richard
ever I I can't think about it you know I
just got to play the game and and do
everything I can to help my team win and
you know if I'm remembered at the end
that would be really cool when our
appreciate and again and uh before I let
you go here I would be remiss certainly
here on on MLK Day to ask you about the
advancement of certainly people of color
in the Rooney Rule and and coaching in
the National Football League and where
you think that all stands I know you and
I had an interesting Twitter exchange
last week while I was on the air and you
were commenting about the Browns not
choosing your defensive coordinator
Robert Saleh well what what do you think
of the current state of affairs on that
front Richard Sherman
I think it's unfortunate you know I
think it's unfortunate that coach Nick
Cutler have continued to deal with this
issue and you know obviously you know if
I'll play Austin's coordinator who
deserved head coaching job this year and
the enemy and it's like no matter what
their what their resume says what their
reputation I'm how much success they
have in their this league they don't get
the respect or you know the respect
enough to be picked as a head coach
and then you get coaching sue or or who
either come to college or have very
little experience being a head coach or
cool even coordinator for that matter
and they get picked you know it's just
that and so do you real I mean and I
know this may sound in some ways naive
but I'll just ask the question do you
really think it's a it's a certainty
it's a color issue that an owner will
sit there and go I will take somebody
that's not a person of color because I'm
I think a better of that person or they
think they can handle it it really come
down to that in your mind well I think
that's what's crazy
that was quite you you present those
questions to me and I don't mean it to
offend at all but he'll but we get
presented those questions as players and
we're not the ones who make those
decisions you know at the end of the day
the owners make those decisions and
nobody ever acts in that question the
ones who actually can make those
decisions and hire their coaches and
make the hard decisions and can answer
the question whether it's about color or
not those guys don't get ax of questions
and that's that's the frustrating part
you know we have to answer questions
like that one when at the end of the day
I don't have say-so in it you know I
don't get the picture where I would have
picked a coach color I would have picked
whoever is the best man for the job
not my decision and the perfect people
will make those you never get a question
and what is Robert Saleh have that
you've seen that says you know what this
guy would be a great head coach in the
NFL he has all the qualities man he has
he's a great leader he's a great he's
great at adapting to his players he
plays player strength he relates to his
players
he takes input he's he's a he criticized
but never too harshly you know what I
mean he knows how to how to talk to his
players boy
okay and then last one for you the
collective bargaining agreement I know
that your your on occasion when you can
focus on that and your role with the
Players Association there's a lot of
talk that the 17-game schedule has been
agreed to and that a lot of other issues
have been agreed to with the financial
issues outstanding would that be an
accurate assessment of the way things
are right now Richard it would not it
would not be an accurate assessment and
that's the that's also the funny thing
about me too about media and and how
they portray things and how the owners
have its hand in manipulating the media
and lighting the conversation because
we're in no way shape or form
have agreed to 17 games that's a that's
a issue that players strongly strongly
against and just about every player that
I talked to is strongly against it now
it's still a conversation between us and
if players change their mind and in the
future then who knows but that's not
something that that that we agree and
that before what about the idea of a
change in player discipline and also the
way that the league views marijuana use
has that been agreed to as a relaxed
rule no I mean it's been a conversation
but it's kind of been in the background
obviously there's there's been more
important conversations about about
revenue and and discipline and obviously
the schedule so it hasn't been at the
forefront all right and then Richard I
really appreciate the time I'm one of
the last times I saw you was after you
blew out your Achilles on the sidelines
in Arizona and just seeing you that
night knowing what your future was
holding was a ton of rehab and then the
ability to maybe find another spot if
not Seattle was just beginning to dawn
on you the fact that I'm talking to you
here today with you being a Superbowl
cornerback that you helped seal with an
interception I just wanted to say
congratulations and I
appreciate know right back at you I'm
just again that night I saw you and all
of us from NFL Network saw you and used
you know you knew what you had in front
of you and the fact that you made it
happen has got to be quite a good
feeling for you it is great feeling it
is it is an indescribable feeling and
I'm just thankful to be able to sturdy
thankful for my teammates and hope just
continue yep and then in congrats on the
Walter Payton Man of the Year nomination
for you in Sanford's for the 49ers as
well thank you so much right now no no
look maybe we'll chalk it talking a
couple weeks how about that okay thanks
they call Richard really appreciate it
that is Richard Sherman at at our
Sherman underscore 25 on Twitter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app